i didn't even want to move
i didn't want to move too quick like
because i'm like oh my god if i take the
wrong step i don't know if he can shoot
something that's like
super important i don't know if he could
shoot me and kill me like were you
afraid for your life at that point i was
really scared because i had never been
shot at before gail here's another great
and big get for you um
megan reached out to you is that true
yeah she did i mean
listen kevin it's been two years july
2020. they reached out and said you know
megan is ready to talk because i think
she was just fed up with the narrative
that's out she wanted to control her own
story you know this is what's so sad to
me is that there's videotape
there's a medical report there is a
police report and there are still people
that are trolling megan online and i
think she ignored it for as long as she
could i really do believe that and then
i think it just got to her and so for
better or worse she said i want to say
something hopefully people will believe
her but but now she can at least say i
stood in my truth and i told and i told
my story so i just said
i stepped on glass so when i see
people trying to use that against me
like trying to act like i'm lying oh she
stepped on glass she never got shot
i don't know what said i slept on glass
i was mine to protect all of us
and sometimes i wish i really would have
never said that you wish you would have
just told the truth i wish i would have
told the truth but
i if it saved
all of us from dying then that's just
probably what it was meant to be when
you hear her the pain in her voice and
you hear her reasoning it's true she
didn't tell the exact truth that night
she did say that she stepped on glass
and when you realize why she said that
think of the circumstances this is july
2020. george floyd it happened may 2020.
everybody's on heightened awareness she
was thinking you know the police come
she knows there's a hot gun in the car
she's thinking how is this going to turn
out for any of us for any of us and so
her immediate go-to was let's do the
best i can to get out of this situation
half the time i just want to pick up the
phone and call my mom and be like what
do i do like
it's too much
i feel crazy
i'm sad like and i feel like i have to
hold it in because i have to be strong
for so many people my heart really went
out to her this is somebody her she lost
her mother in 2019 yep brain cancer she
lost her father a while ago
you know she said i really wanted
friends i was i thought these i thought
these people were my friends i did say
maybe you need to get better friends you
also need to stay off of social media
because social media will take you into
a dark hole and it's very difficult to
get out i thought this was interesting
she said tori and i had bonded because
he had lost his mother i had lost my
mother they had certainly had
conversations about that i could see
where that would draw you i could i
could see where you could think we have
something in common as terrible as this
is we can communicate with each other
that turned out not to be the case so
why do you think he's putting out the
story that the two of you had a
relationship and that you're making the
whole thing up i think that he is trying
to deflect
from the fact that he committed a crime
tory lanez pleaded not guilty to assault
and weapons charges related to the
shooting i would love to talk to tory
lanez if he ever wanted to speak as well
we certainly have an open invitation
to him we reached out his to his
attorney and we got the traditional you
know we don't have anything to say at
this particular time but i think it's
deeply affected her because again it
goes back to
her saying i thought this person was my
friend
that's what i thought
and then when she tells exactly what
happened that night the fact that people
don't believe her kevin despite video
evidence
i i think is painful to her what do you
say to people that still don't believe
that you were actually shot i don't
think any of this is for them like it's
for me like i know this happened to me
and
i'll rather it play out in court and the
facts come out and everything comes out
than me having to
plead my case and i
i'm a victim like i'm the victim like i
don't i'm not defending myself against
anything like something happened to me
these were not crocodile tears this
wasn't something a woman who was playing
for the camera i mean and it was real
consistently throughout the interview
you know i i was surprised that the
tears were still so fresh right there
two years later but i think when you
think about it when you think about it
that you could have lost your life
you could have lost your life that night
by someone who you thought was a friend
i see why it's still so raw and so
painful for her i'm hoping today that
she feels lighter that she feels i i
told my truth i told my story and now
people don't believe me it's on them
i've at least i've at least done my part
that i'm hoping she feels much better
today
[Music]